foreign
Teddy is with us in New York City hi
teddy how are you
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
thank you for having me on the show
again I called you last year to get a
little guidance in terms of my career
and whatnot especially financially and
just to kind of remind you you told me
to potentially hold off on my masters
I'm going to be pursuing that due to the
fact that I just got engaged over the
summer and my fiance has one more year
in the same school so we're just going
to finish up our degrees her undergrad
and meet grad school and then head to
the beautiful state of Florida
um but my goal long term is to have a
good career and more importantly to have
Financial stability ideally in the
aspect of real estate passive income and
whatnot
um I have no real guidance in that
regard so I'd love to get your take on
it what's your Masters in
mechanical engineering and what what
career are you pursuing after this
mechanical engineering okay do you have
a job already lined up
I had a couple for this cup for this
year but like I said I decided to just
get my masters it just didn't seem
reasonable to take a job for one year
and then you know head to a different
state
okay
um in addition to that my Master's
Degree only costs less than 14k for the
whole program and I'm currently debt
free as well so um it's something that I
can reasonably pay off while I'm in
school that's awesome how did you pay
for your education
um predominantly through scholarships
and some financial aid I'm in New York
so
there's a lot of that that's awesome I'm
all for you buying buying some real
estate
um uh but when idiots on the internet
say real estate is passive income
that means they've never owned any
because there's nothing passive about
dealing with renters
and heat and air heat and air that goes
out and roofs that leak and a coach
Department shows up and wants to shut
you down because somebody across the
street cut a sewer line there's nothing
passive about managing real estate
nothing whatsoever you want Passive by
mutual fund they'll just put the check
in your mailbox and you won't think
anything about it but real estate ain't
passive
it's very active even if you're managing
the managing company they've still got
to call you and approve the 8 400 New
Heating and Air system that blew up or
the other day I had a 26 thousand dollar
one go out on one of our commercial
buildings didn't feel passive to me at
all so um
anyway I love real estate but please
enjoy the idea that this is going to be
some hassle factor that other
Investments don't have it does give you
a better rate of return that other
Investments don't have but when I hear
someone say passive income and real
estate in the same sentence it means
they've been on get rich quick websites
because they make it sound like oh well
the renters will just pay for it uh nope
you're going to pay for it maybe the
renters pay you
uh that's how it works in the real world
so you know go buy you some real estate
after you get your life started and pay
cash for it after you get your home paid
off and after you get your 401ks and
other stuff started but um this idea
that you're going to build a portfolio
of uh heavily debt written real estate
and the renters are all going to make
you rich is is so freaking laughable
that it makes my head spin and it's all
by people who have never done it before
well and you're in such a good spot
right now you went through college debt
free you're walking straight into baby
steps four five and six I think that's
really where your focus needs to be
right now real estate can happen someday
but focus on retirement starting out and
and get that primary residence in place
and pay that off once you get to that
spot then we can start talking about
really investing in real estate for
profit but you've got some very clear
steps ahead and if you do that right
you're gonna really especially at the
age you're at right now set yourself up
for Success versus getting kind of lost
in this get rich quick world that's so
prevalent right now like you said on
Tick Tock and Instagram it's like very
very popular but it's also really
leading a lot of new grads down some
crazy routes yeah and sometimes
sometimes people misunderstand my
sarcasm or anger at that stuff like it's
because it disagrees with me that's not
it at all it's I know what it's going to
do to you
when they mislead you
and you people listening go along with
some of the stupid butt stuff that is
out there you're gonna you're gonna end
up like I did in my 20s broke
I followed the same siren song the exact
same one only it was just the 1980s
version okay and uh and although if you
just didn't understand listen honey I I
believe me if there's only if there's
one thing I know how to do it's numbers
okay so I completely understood and I
did it with Great Gusto uh starting from
nothing in three years I had over a
million dollar net worth 125 properties
okay so starting from nothing in three
years so I didn't half butt do it I did
it all out I mean
PhD and dumb and I knocked it out in a
short period of time you know so and
here's the thing I discovered Christina
not directed at him by the way for you
sir you are an engineer which is the
number one of all careers most likely to
be a millionaire when we started
millionaires number one was engineer
number two is accountant number three
was teacher okay so you got a lot of
good stuff on your side just don't fall
into get rich quick so in our day
they didn't call it passive income they
called it nothing down and there was a
guy that wrote the book called the book
was called nothing down it was a
best-selling book
and and a whole bunch of people
including me followed a lot of his
strategies on buying a house with no
money because that's precisely how much
money I had none so that's all I could
use so I used other people's money OPM
talked the bank in 100 financing 90 day
notes I bought a property made money on
it bought another property made money on
it every time I made money off the
banker gave me more money it was a nice
formula and until it wasn't nice anymore
and uh you know a few years later the
guy that wrote the book went into
bankruptcy
ouch I joined a group an Investors Group
a Real Estate Investors Group that were
following this guy's he put together
groups and cities they were following
this guy's guidelines and got to be
friends with a bunch of guys we would
you know one of us we couldn't do a deal
we found a deal we'd find somebody else
to do the deal we'd give it to one of
our buddies right and we swapped it
around there was about I was probably 60
people in that group that were doing
this stuff actively 10 years later
from the time we all started that how
many of them
were still buying real estate and not
broke
none nobody made it not one I take that
back two guys made it but the reason
they made it was they woke up watching
the rest of us go broke and they turned
a whole bunch of their properties took
the equities and paid off the rest they
became debt free and they came out of it
with about 30 percent of the property
but it was all debt free instead of
Leverage to their eyeballs and they they
you know they re they reverse engineered
and got out with the skin by the skin of
their teeth and I ran into one of those
guys the other day that was 30 years ago
he's still buying real estate and he's
still healthy but he was one of the few
smart enough to look at the rest of us
and going these fools are all going
broke doing the same thing and I was one
of those fools so you know but you find
people get rich in real estate they're
not ones that leverage up to their
eyeballs it's hard to find somebody
follows this passive income crap and 10
years later is not broke it's very
difficult to find 10 years later a real
estate investor that follows that plan
they're they're very rare they're
unicorns but you can still invest in
real estate I mean cash for it look at
you now real estate but just pay cash
for it and grow slower and don't try to
go follow all this
mind-numbing get rich quick stuff